hello and welcome to another episode of
conan o'brien needs friend i do have
some friends but you can always use a
few more who are these friends the ones
that i really have let's not get into
that don't dig too deep
i don't know people people who have
friends don't go like i have a lot of
friends i do i do what i have
does that give away the fact that i
really don't have real friends the fact
that i
constantly only does that i have friends
you don't think i have friends
i have lots of friends sir you got very
defensive sorry just pay for the
unleaded gas and go but i do have
friends
of course i just put the nozzle back and
uh and i don't use unleaded i use
premium well you didn't have friends ask
them okay sir who are your friends i
gotta go
um
that's also the voice i use when i'm not
broadcasting when i'm not on television
or i'm not doing a podcast or some kind
of personal appearance this is how i
really talk
which is always a huge shock people on
the street are always saying hey are you
conor buying that's right
bingo you got it right on the nose oh oh
and i go oh sorry hold on a second would
this be better for you
yeah what was that other voice oh that's
how i really talk
well gotta go and then i get on a
unicycle
and i have a little horn that goes
bye-bye ta-da and i uh drive away a
little window into my life some people
say pretty big windows comedians don't
really open up
but i just did i just made myself very
vulnerable with that story
and told you about the real me
and um
yeah
well i really brought the
tone down
i'm sure there are people that were
listening to the podcast that when i was
doing that bit i use that voice
turn down
their
you know whether it's their phone
or whatever they're listening to this on
their computer
you couldn't think of anything i know
you wanted to say radio so bad or the
television i feel like he really wanted
to say television i did want to say
television
and i did want to say radio i did but
now um you've busted me again because uh
that's also true i don't have friends
and i really do wish
that everybody listened to this on a
mahogany curve top radio
just before i came on the announcer said
well that does it for little orphan
annie today
and remember use crisco and you're doing
your deep frying we'll have a fireside
chat with president franklin roosevelt
in about half an hour but until then
conan o'brien is coming to us from his
broadcast booth in los angeles coding
and that people were huddled around and
they were wearing
farmers bib overalls
because they had been working in the
fields all day trying to avoid the dust
from the dust bowl and just
just hovered around listening to conan's
soothing tones
but no that's not the world i live in i
live in a world of
various downloads
you couldn't even get that out dynamic
ad insertions
i don't even know when they'll say that
conan it's a dynamic ad insertion and
i'll say what do you mean it's an ad
that comes on when the podcast airs the
podcast doesn't air the podcast exists
in the cloud it is it's it's meta it's
everywhere all the time and you access
it what no what it's not what is it
do you know what the how do i explain
what the podcast is to my parents they
don't know they don't listen to it my
brother neil won't listen to it because
it doesn't happen on television or the
radio and i'll say it's hosted on a
server and downloaded by a user how's
that that just sounds like porn
what kind of porn are you watching do
you download your portal i download it i
can stream it it's so much better to
stream it than i want to make sure that
i can save it for later so i download it
and i have it and then i have it burned
onto cellophane so that i can yeah
excuse me
not
well you know let me cover quickly for
myself
i use cellophane because celluloid has
been proven to be the worst way
to to show film you know what i don't
know the word for anything i don't know
the word for anything anymore i promised
you did something recently that i would
not let you live down and i have to
bring it up because this will already be
out by then but we are on a zoom and uh
the lovely editor mars who works on the
ads for this show had her background was
from the video game animal crossing and
you in all sincerity went wow you have a
beautiful living room and it was like
pink wood like a rabbit lipped yeah i'm
going to admit that mars who by the way
shout out to mars she's very cool does
great work for the podcast uh and she
had this background
in my defense it was a slight it was a
small box there were many boxes up so
it's not like i was watching it on a
giant screen on this zoom but i
complimented her on her lovely creative
kind of cool
etsy styled room
and then it turned out she had to tell
me that no this is from what is it from
again animal crossing and that um and by
the way just so you know this this video
game is not like a photo realistic video
game it's like kind of like the smurfs
no it really was if someone had put up
as their background the living room from
the flintstones and i said oh i love
your rock apartment i think that's
really beautiful um
so oh god
all of you laughed really hard because
ha ha conan's an idiot um who doesn't
understand how things work
and okay i guess we're done
also you you never go you never go oh
i'm sorry i i was wrong you were like no
that living room looks very real and
everyone's like it's a cartoon and
you're like no no no but from my
perspective like you just couldn't go on
to gaslight us yes i
i'm always always hoping that i can get
myself out of trouble if i just keep
talking and so that is my modus operandi
and so i just thought if i keep talking
i'll hit upon something they will make
you guys go oh i guess i that kind of
makes sense and then i'm in the clear
and then i get to
[ __ ] on you guys for even thinking that
i was wrong